it is a tradition celebrated by many to
honor those who've passed away different
cultures know it as all souls day dia de
los muertos or day of the dead christian
casa is joining us now live tonight near
woodlawn cemetery where some families
have started this celebration of life
christian
that's right well it truly is a
celebration of the continuation of life
many families that we spoke to today say
that regardless of the language the food
and the music the focus remains the same
take a look as you can see many families
starting to slowly flow into the
cemetery and it's almost like a sea of
lights if you can see just across here
across the cemetery many of those lights
are tombstones that have been cleaned
and decorated with candles and flowers
and ofrendas families remembering those
who have passed while keeping their name
alive
tradition like you know i grew up with a
somber yet joyful day for this filipino
family today they are at this las vegas
cemetery celebrating the life of one of
their own who passed away in 2019 to
parkinson's disease a filipina delicacy
like
we call it suman like a rice cake
whatever you go to the
cemetery having
like a party ride a traditional and
cultural gathering by many families on
november first and the second involving
music food and colorful decorations
known as all souls day or day of the
dead our cameras capturing some families
prepping for the celebration of life
while others kept celebrations more
personal i miss him
i have you know it's been about five to
six years on most terms that he's passed
away we met christina da silva at her
husband's grave she celebrates his life
by honoring their culture while helping
others on the day of the dead we have a
lot of beggars so we will call them and
we will
feed them in the name of our
our loved ones many families telling us
the pandemic forced smaller gatherings
at home while others say every day is a
celebration of life we have a lot of fun
memories of him
well back out here live you can see just
how colorful and just all the work that
each family puts into this day which is
just so personal and so very special to
so many families now many of them
telling us that they plan to be out here
today and tomorrow in the company of
those who have passed away christian
cassette is live local now